موقف قطر كان واضحا جدا
فنحن ضد أي عمل عدواني أو أي
أه تهديد باستخدام القوة أو
استخدام القوة ضد دولة ذات سيادة
أو
أنتم تعرفون محاولة النيل من
وحدة أراضي
أي دولة وقد
أوضحنا هذا أه بجلاء  علينا أن
نلتزم بالنفط
الدولي واللامبالغة
وهذا يحتاج إلى احترام
لأنه بخلاف ذلك سيكون العالم في
حالة من الفوضى ،
لذلك
نحافظ على قناة اتصالنا
مع جميع الأطراف التي كنت في موسكو
منذ حوالي 10 أيام ، أتيحت لي
الفرصة  لإجراء محادثة مع وزير
خارجية روسيا تتحدث عن
القضية الأوكرانية ولكن أيضًا الحفاظ على
الاتصال مستمر مع
نظرائنا الأوكرانيين الذين
يحاولون
مساعدتنا أو عرض مساعدتنا أو
مساهمتنا في وصف الموقف
ووضع حد لهذه الحرب ،
هل تعتقد أن  يريد الرئيس بوتين
السلام في هذه المرحلة ،
حسنًا ، لا يمكنني حقًا أن أقول
ما يفكر فيه الرئيس بوتين ولكن ما
أؤمن به ومن خلال حديثي  أنا مع
نظيري هناك في روسيا
بأنهما على استعداد للانخراط في
المطالب التي قدموها الآن إلى أي
مدى ترغب الحكومة الأوكرانية
[الموسيقى]
في التنازل عن هذه المطالب ، فهذا
حقًا قرار الحكومة
الأوكرانية والشعب الأوكراني
ولكن
اهتمامنا الآن
هو والأولوية حقًا
خلق بيئة آمنة
للأشخاص المدنيين هناك
تدهور في الوضع الإنساني
في أوكرانيا
وهو أمر غير مسبوق ، لذا أعتقد أنه
يجب أن تكون الأولوية يجب أن نركز
على وجود  الممرات الإنسانية لوقف إطلاق النار
تجلب المساعدات الإنسانية
إلى أوكرانيا وبدلاً من أن يكون هناك
هذا
الصراع وهذا الاتفاق في
ساحة معركة ليكون حول الطاولة
، فرض الغرب
عقوبات متأرجحة
على روسيا
في محاولة للضغط
على الكرملين في هذه المرحلة أم
الاستثمار القطري  سلطة قطر لديها
استثمار كبير أه في عملاق النفط الروسي
روسنفت
مستعدة قطر
بالانسحاب من روسيا هل تفكك
هذا الموقف بشكل جيد في الواقع أه الآن
مع الوضع الحالي نحن لا
نفكر في أي أه استثمارات جديدة
هناك
[موسيقى]
حتى بالمناسبة في
أوروبا حتى يكون لدينا بعض الوضوح بشأن
استقرار الوضع ولكن
أنت تعلم أن قراراتنا وأننا
أخذنا الاستثمار في ذلك الوقت
بناءً على تقييم تجاري
وهذه الاستثمارات لا تزال جارية
لذلك لن تقوم بأي استثمارات جديدة
في الوقت الحالي في البيئة الحالية أعتقد
أن الاستثمار
حقًا أه في
ظل  الكثير من المراجعات ، فك
الصندوق السيادي النرويجي موقفه
في
الشركات الروسية ،
فأنت تقول إن
الاستثمار القطري في روسيا قيد
المراجعة في هذه المرحلة
للوقت الحالي ، والآن في الوقت الحالي ،
تستند قراراتنا الاستثمارية كما أخبرتك إلى  في
التقييم
التجاري وما لدينا حاليًا في روسيا
، لا نفكر في زيادة
ذلك
هذه الأيام حتى نرى أجواء أفضل
هـ والمزيد من الاستقرار السياسي